well the grammar police are coming for
the word the no seriously the AP style
book is recommending in a now deleted
tweet avoiding labels like the poor the
mentally ill and the French claiming it
is dehumanizing as you can imagine folks
on social media mocked the change
immediately this includes the French
Embassy they tweeted this picture of
them changing their handle to quote
Embassy of frenchness in the U.S well AP
later apologized for offending the
French
um Jesse
what do you think this show should be
renamed since it can no longer be called
the five do you have any ideas yeah
hosts of the five no you can't use the
oh is that dehumanizing yeah five-ish
what about It's Five O'Clock Somewhere
I like that perfect
but that means you're caving to style so
I like dehumanizing the French I don't
know I think we need to I've had enough
of them the French on their high horse
they could use you know a little knock
down on their high horse you know how
they are tell us more about their high
horse they are very snobby to how clear
do I have to be just Parisian about the
food about their culture about their art
about their language need I say more did
they not seat you at a table when you
went to France is that the problem you
know what I did I ate at McDonald's when
I went to France yes I did I heard that
they have very fancy McDonald's they're
beautiful yeah is it really yeah what is
it better but it's the same food yeah
well the food is delicious first of all
it's a hamburger it's more than a
hamburger a McDonald's burger is special
do we need to get back on topic or no
don't they have plastic in the meat or
something no they're an issue I mean
maybe I'm sure there was a lot forget it
that's something I read um what do you
think what do you want to call it the
style handbook which is so such a great
resource for a lot of organizations it's
not ours uh at Fox we don't have to lean
on it therefore these this style
handbook wants to get on our show wants
to be in our Network so they say
something totally ridiculous and they
now become important again we don't want
to have style and wherefore we will not
be the French we will not be uh anything
that is dehumanizing we will not
characterize things that way uh the
mentally ill they don't want to hear
that the mentally ill have not weighed
in but the style people say the mentally
ill do not want to hear one of them is
weighing it right
do not encourage her Jesse please I mean
where does this happen Okay I just want
to apologize to the French I I actually
really like French culture French
history they're a great Ally and I take
back everything I said well wait a
minute did anybody come to me did I say
anything
okay here's it I don't care what you
think I don't care what you want me to
say it's none of your business what
comes out of my mouth
right kinda what'd you get with her well
because we have to go to commercial
breakdown we don't have time why do you
want her to yell at me well I'm just
saying my pen at you I mean Jillian is
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else